let's go to your voicemail two one nine
two david p this voicemail whoever made
this voicemail is not going to be happy
with that last segment we just did take
a listen to this david this is Alan in
San Diego my wife and I watch you on
free speech TV and we believe yours is
one of their best that said we know
there's a distinction between the
programs of May 30th and May 31st I'm
not speaking of the difference between
the studio environment of the 30th and
what appeared to be a room in a home the
following day instead I'm referring to
the time spent on the 30th with the chat
and the photos the beer-drinking shot
for example regarding your canadian
vacation and frankly any vacation for
that matter respectfully we believe that
the bonus show is the better venue for
the personal non-political items the
free-speech Pakman show thanks to you
and that is at its best
concise issue-by-issue review of the
day's political news and the rest of it
is simply a speed bump in the wrong
place
think it over please okay so I will
definitely don't agree with this I think
that if the entire show were about my
Canadian vacation there would be a
problem but there's been generally a
warm reception to sprinkling in personal
anecdotes and whatnot I don't think it's
a problem if we're doing seven or eight
news stories and then I put up a picture
of me on vacation and some of the
comments people had about it I think by
and large we're providing the bulk of
the show is news and Paul and political
analysis I respectfully disagree with
this caller but I appreciate their
willingness to give us their feedback
and I don't know if he knows this but
there was really do with Instagram a
tree mail with the reddit posts and I
think people by and large like those I
think so I think so
and not everybody likes every aspect of
the show but the idea is there's
something for everyone all right on the
bonus show today
another Pastafarian driver's license
picture with a pasta strainer Curiosity
rover has found that
crater was habitable for 700 million
years and much much more we've got a
great bonus show coming up today sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership
coupon code is available I voted 17 I
will speak to you then